the last time I saw you you had a
birthday party at your home and I went
there and you had a cake this was you
had a cake specially designed for your
birthday party
it featured you and your husband mr.
Nick Offerman let's take a look at this
cake there's a picture here of the cake
[Laughter]
okay yeah so I remembered that cake was
wheeled out first of all I want to point
out Nick's creepy leering in the
background of it he looks like a guy
who'd be asked to leave the bus station
so wait so that cake a very provocative
cake and then I found out that here we
are we're in LA very progressive you had
a hard time getting a baker that would
make that cake oh yeah most bakeries
said no well all bakery said no until
that one said yes so wait and so what
happened you showed them like a drawing
of what you wanted or photograph and
they were like no we're not doing that
uh that's right we took a photo and so
we want our faces on oh no excuse me I
don't want to ruin the yeah illusion
that that's really us but no no one no
one would do it no one would do it I
could see like a Carvel ice cream store
like a chain not wanting to do it but it
must be it must get a little
embarrassing when time after time you're
trying to get someone to make a cake and
they're like no I won't do it I won't do
it but I'm glad you found someone that
would do it
yeah well thank you for doing it it
turned out great
[Laughter]
[Applause]
filthy bakery just really taking up
that's where all the money is these days
I leave here and I make it a cake